there's far too many people who think
that bullying is a rite of passage if
you have severe bullying other
researchers have shown that it affects
your immune response for decades it
affects the expression of your genes for
decades it's not a minor thing
why did you get interested in studying
bullying
it actually was kind of by accident uh
Wendy Craig at Queen's University
had a whole pile of data and she needed
a PhD student to work on it
um I was friends with her and I said
sure I'll look at it so I ended up
looking at it and then over time as I
was a professor more and more students
wanted to do research on bullying and it
eventually became my main focus what do
you think is unique or novel about the
approach that you've taken to looking at
bully
yeah the biggest thing is that our group
really asks why Bullying happens seeing
as it's ubiquitous over time across
cultural and really hard to prevent it
seems like either development has gone
wrong for so many people or maybe
there's something in it for the bullies
um okay so how do you define bullying
what is it
yeah another great question
um we Define bullying as a deliberate uh
aggressive attempt against a weaker
individual that causes harm so it's got
to be gold directed
it's got to uh be something that causes
harm so it can't be a meaningless thing
and most importantly it has to happen in
the context where the victim has a hard
time defending themselves that's the
power imbalance
so bullying in that regard can't happen
to somebody who is of equal status or
higher status than you exactly that
would be General aggression but that
wouldn't be bullying interesting okay so
what's the evolutionary hypothesis
behind bullying what have you come to
believe about it
so
bullying uh at first seems a little
counter-intuitive from an evolutionary
perspective and that what you often find
is that in nature there's dominatories
so bullying is often confused with the
alpha male beta male Etc but it's really
unusual in dominance hierarchies for
number two to pick on number 17 in the
hierarchy that's the whole point of the
Dominator they shouldn't be fighting
so we think bullying has a few different
functions some of them depend on that
hierarchy and some don't the ones that
don't are pretty easy to explain you're
bullying somebody to get something that
you want so you want the resources
um you want the best spot in the play
yard you want that scholarship that
they're going for that you're interested
in
but when it comes to bullying for
dominance we actually don't think that
it's a direct competition between
competitors
instead what bullying is it's a way of
signaling how dangerous you are to
compete with so why is number two
punching number 17 number 17 isn't a
threat number 17 doesn't have things
that they need socially but what number
two is doing is showing number one and
number three what they're capable of
doing and they're picking a Target
that's a reasonable threat so if you
were uh a 10 year old and you're beating
up a four-year-old that's not really
impressive right if you're in grade 12
and you're picking on a Grade 9 that's
not really going to intimidate the other
people but on the other hand if you're a
grade 12 or a 12 year old picking on up
here then that's showing your peers what
you're willing and capable of doing to
other peers and it seems to be quite
effective
does that mean that bullying is
increased when there is an audience of
some kind
that's a really great question
um a lot of bullying that we've observed
happens with an audience over 80 percent
of bullying that we've observed uh again
colleague Wendy Craig and dad probably
did a beautiful study kind of like a BBC
documentary where they put microphones
on kids sent them into the playground
and then filmed them from a distance
and they saw that 85 percent of the time
when somebody was bullying somebody else
they were uh surrounded by peers
that would explain this sort of almost
performative
aspect of it it's a very heavy signal
yeah we can talk about private bullying
so you could bully your uh sexual
partner into things that you might not
want public but as far as the majority
of bullying that you see uh on the
playground especially in its schools as
well as in a lot of workplaces is done
performatively to show other people what
you're capable of and that they should
not mess with you
interesting
what are the most common
uh setups or Dynamics between a bully
and a victim
yeah we for a long time thought that
the problem was of one of a relationship
that the bullying the victim didn't get
along and if we could somehow sit down
the Lamb with a lion then things would
be better
but Recent research has shown a few
really interesting things that go
against the idea that there's this
perfect setup
um or a mismatch between individuals
number one is that interventions that
sit the land down with the lion are
iatrogenic which means they make things
worse so what happens is for the next
few weeks The Bullying goes down and
then the bullying goes to higher than it
was beforehand which sort of makes sense
you put the bully with the victim in
front of adults and okay the bully plays
nice for two weeks and then as soon as
the adults are done looking they get the
revenge
the other thing that some Dutch
researchers have done
is shown that bullies cycle victims they
don't just pick one victim and they
cycle through one victim after another
and the more that they do that the
higher their reputation increases the
greater their popularity and their
dominance so it really seems like it's a
signal
beyond that uh victims tend to uh have
weaker levels of power so they're less
uh socially connected they're more
likely to have mental health issues to
begin with that bullying exacerbates
um and then bullies are very good at
finding victims that they can Target so
if you have a bully who's physically
strong they'll pick on a physically weak
individual somebody's socially strong
will pick on a socially isolated
individual somebody who's mentally and
socially quick will pick on somebody who
doesn't have strong mental or social
skills so the bullies are very flexible
in choosing the right target for them
what else predicts a bully victim you've
mentioned what seems to be social
isolation lack of a support network I'm
going to imagine that the fewer friends
you have the more likely you are to be
bullied yeah absolutely physical size
not surprisingly
um younger age if you're younger within
the grade or younger overall and then
now we're currently looking at
adolescence you know the data in but I
suspect we're going to find that being
isolated from the dating game is also an
important factor
now for aggression
you tend to find that being involved in
the dating game makes you more likely to
be targeted by aggression but that's by
uh equal level peers yep yep yep so
being picked on by stronger people is
usually again these kids who are sending
the right cost benefit signal so
somebody who's strong enough that the
signal has meaning but somebody who's
weak enough that the bully isn't going
to be uh successfully retaliated against
and Bullies will look at your social
network and say okay well those people
who the victim is connected with I don't
care about their opinions they're a safe
Target but that hit over there he's
friends with a girl who I like so
they're off limits
so it's very strategic it's interesting
that there's almost like this Goldilocks
zone where below a particular threshold
of weakness or vulnerability uh the
there is no point in the bully doing it
because what are you signaling you can
obviously beat up now imagine that you
would maybe verbally take the piss
because
I guess that that shows still that
you're quick comparatively but certainly
doing something physical wouldn't make
sense I guess this must raise some
questions for kids being skipped ahead a
year or two in school because what
you're doing is immediately putting
somebody who is physically mentally
socially less Adept in where the pool of
people that are more likely to be
bullies
yeah that's a good example of a
situation that could very easily
backfire
um
because it's very it bullies are very
skilled at saying oh we're just taking
the piss out of this guy we're just
having fun we're teasing goofing around
um and they're especially as kids get
older they do less physical building
boys do more physical bullying than
girls there's a surprise City more
physical aggression of all kinds but as
kids get older you know if you have a
couple of eight-year-olds punching
another kid it's not that bad in terms
of the physical damage if you have a
couple of 18 year olds wailing away on
somebody you know bones are broken
things are chipped so they shift to
these uh verbal and social forms of
bullying that are in a sense less risky
for the bully but they're also much
harder to detect and prevent
okay so what sort of people bully what
are the typical characteristics of
someone that is a bully
yeah again one of the things that you
know we went into this was the
assumption that these aren't broken kids
um and the first thing that steered me
in this direction was I was working on
that original data set 10 000 kids uh
from the World Health Organization they
look at kids school health
and 10 000 kids in Canada
and I noticed that bullies yes were more
likely to smoke more likely to drink
alcohol
but they had better mental health than
average which didn't fit with the
picture that these are kids who have
poor self-esteem uh who have poor social
skills and in fact research has shown
that they don't have deficits in uh
mental health they don't have deficits
in social skills they don't have
deficits and things like theory of Mind
understanding other people's thoughts
and ideas
they don't even necessarily have
deficits in empathy and in anger
what they have is low levels of a trait
that we call honesty humility
so honesty humility is part of the
hexaco uh it's a six-factor personality
scale a really new Dynamic personality
scale that really captures any social
behavior with this trait and essentially
honestly humility I like it because it
sounds innocuous
what does that have to do with anything
but really if you take the belief that
you're better than other people you
deserve more than other people
and you're willing to act on that belief
then that sets you up for saying number
17 sorry this is the way the world works
it's Doggy Dog nothing personal but I'm
better than you and I'm going to show
people it and if you weren't such a
crappy kid or stupid slow ugly you know
no friends then this wouldn't be
happening to you
so that's really the biggest predictor
that we find across cultures we've seen
it now in Chinese data and Dutch data
and Canadian and North American data
that this honesty humility is really
what's driving uh individuals to engage
in that behavior along with having power
so another really interesting study from
the Netherlands showed that not only do
police gain in popularity uh when they
engage in bullying the kids who become
more popular power corrupts them and
they become more likely to be bullies
themselves
right so there are a lot of incentives
here for a bully to bully aside from
presuming that you have low honesty
humility which I'm going to guess would
be associated with things like guilt
shame regret for social infractions and
treating somebody miserably
if you're not feeling the pain from that
if you're benefiting by having more
social prowess uh by rising up through
your own dominance hierarchy more
Prestige uh greater social uh circles
also didn't you do something that looked
at uh more access to sexual partners
they have sex sooner or more regularly
or something
yeah that's one of the main benefits
from an evolutionary perspective all
this other stuff is nice but if you
don't translate into passing on your
genes it doesn't matter
so we did a study uh that kind of
surprised us it hit number seven on
Reddit when it came out that bullies
have more sex
um than non-bullies and that accounted
for both uh early adolescence and in
later in adolescence both boys and girls
so it wasn't a case that uh it was just
you know dominant boys monopolizing a
gene pool but
um both dominant boys and dominant girls
use bullying to get sex and then
recently a team from Europe
again Netherlands and some folks from
the UK as well looked at uh
I'm trying to think of how I think it
was almost 50 years now at least 40
years ago but uh data on bullies from
the late 70s and they showed that these
bullies actually have more kids
and we've done this follow-up study uh
looking at 30 year olds uh and 30 year
olds who were bullies in high school
have more kids
that's very interesting I'm trying to
work out what direction this Arrow of
causation goes for instance you could
just have people who are more likely to
bully
are more tapped in socially therefore
their sociosexuality would be higher
it's not necessarily that by bullying
you gain more access to mates which
means that you then get more sex which
means that you then have more kids
because I don't think that that would
explain particularly well why girls
would get more access maybe some
intersexual competition stuff here that
you've derogated some female Rivals and
you rise up but I don't know man like
even when I was a young full of magic
and RuneScape 15 year old I don't think
I thought the girls that bullied were
like more hot or charming I can see it
in reverse everybody could understand
why the you know the dominant guy that
wears the leather jacket with cut off
sleeves and stands with one foot up
against a wall smoking a cigarette why
he might be highly prized by the women
but I I don't think that it would work
in Reverse so yeah I wonder whether
sociosexuality just kind of folds into
this more the most socially Adept
they're more socially tuned in they're
playing that dominance and that status
full game and that means that Downstream
from that they're also playing the
flirting game and the dating game and
the having kids game
yeah that's exactly right I think it's a
bi-directional pathway
um and in the case of girls we know that
kids who victimized uh are less likely
to have sex and less likely to date so
bullying is an effective way of knocking
out some competitors and intimidating
others if you see the movie Mean Girls
it's often the prototype for girls
bullying and they're pretty nasty with
each other when it comes to guys
attention and so certainly intra-sexual
competition is important
intersexually these girls uh are
dominants securing the resources and we
know that in our species men compete for
women not as much as in the other way
but a woman who is good at getting
resources and good at taking care of her
kids when you think in Canada here we
talk about the hockey moms uh in the US
and UK is probably soccer moms right uh
maybe southern us it's the football moms
those moms are intimidating and perhaps
attractive to to the male partners
because they say look you know she's
going to look after my kids and get them
what they want and knock the other kids
out of the way for them
so there's benefits directly and then of
course personality underlying bullying
also really overlaps with social
sexuality right so given the fact that
I'm not massively familiar with hexaco
um so big five is at least what I have a
bit of an Insight in and it seems like
there's a good bit of crossover I know
that the the C and the O and the a uh
have a bit of crossover
um
given the fact that one of the best
predictors for this is honesty humility
given the fact that almost all
personality traits are very highly
heritable 50 on average I don't know
what honesty humility is does that mean
that bullying is heritable
yes
bullying has a high degree of genetic
heritability UH 60 70 now it's important
for folks to know that that doesn't mean
bullying is 60 to 70 caused by genes
means the differences between average
individuals and Western samples 60 to 70
percent of that difference can be
explained by genetics
hexaco is like
um the big five but much better
it's got better cross-cultural growing
shade throwing shade at the big five oh
I I the guy who came up with it is at my
University along with Kim Lee Mike
Ashton
um and they were trying to replicate the
big five as grad students across
cultures and it didn't come out uh as
five in English it comes out as five or
six so the original Big Five creators
took parsimony and said in English we'll
go with five
you're right that there's a lot of
similarities extroversion
conscientiousness openness are similar
but where it's very different
is that the hexaco really maps on well
with evolutionary explanations for
social behavior
so social behavior happens for three
reasons and by social I mean cooperation
mutualism is when you each get something
to benefit from that's uh you know the
cleaner bird picking a crocodile's teeth
they're each getting something direct
from each other Lions helping bring down
prey or helping each other directly
or it happens through kin selection
which means look after similar genes
that's usually nepotism looking after
your family or reciprocal altruism
reciprocal altruism is uh you scratch my
back all scratch ears at a later date
now the hexaco honesty humility maps on
with your willingness to cheat on others
to look after yourself so if you think
of something like the prisoner's dilemma
um it's a willingness to take advantage
of others if you see a wallet with 200
bucks you take the money out before you
even consider returning it
the advantage of that is you selfishly
benefit
the cost is that
um
you get a reputation for being selfish
and people don't like being with you
agreeableness in the hexaco is the
opposite of that how willing are you to
forgive somebody taking advantage of you
so now you and your mate go out for uh
lunch and they forget their wallet say
screw it we're done through you know or
do you
tolerate that and allow it to continue
now obviously that's good for continuing
the relationship but if you're really
agreeable your Ned Flanders people can
take advantage of you
emotionality maps on really nicely with
uh sentimentality and a lack of risk
taking it's the one that has the biggest
sex difference men are a little lower in
honesty humility women are actually a
little lower in agreeableness but women
are much higher emotionality and I'm in
a lower in agreeableness on hexaco
yeah
yeah uh they're more likely
to get angry
um and retaliate than men are is that so
is the hexaco agreeableness a different
measure than the big five agreeableness
yeah big five agreeableness just
basically says nice but it doesn't map
onto the specific function
um so you've got
emotionality which is basically kin
selection
um are you sentimental do you have high
levels of emotional empathy
um do you worry a lot which is what
we've seen a lot of uh mothers and women
that's why you find more vegetarians for
example amongst women
but then the hexago is uh h and a are do
you take advantage of others and do you
let yourself get taken advantage of very
interesting is there a place that people
can do an online test a thorough very
well validated online test that'll
explain the scores for hexaco
yep uh uh hexaco
h-e-x-a-c-o.org
is where uh the creators have that
online test and you can do it online
there and it'll give you a sense of
where you're at and it's really useful
scale
um you know I don't know if we want to
transition a little away from bullying
but one of the more interesting findings
we did in our my career was look at the
big five and other personality measures
predicting the dark Triad
psychopathy uh narcissism
machiavellianism which is basically
scheming strategic
and we found that the hexaco
outperformed uh all the other
personality measures including the big
five
and then the one that really blew us
away uh was a colleague Gordon Hodson
said you know the dark Triad all cluster
together if you think of overlapping
circles because it shares a common core
that Common Core of anti-social
selfishness
and so we look to see how the core of
the dark Triad overlapped with the core
of the hexaco
and I was expecting a correlation to be
pretty big uh 0.5.6 correlation was 0.95
so it's the same thing and that's been
replicated now in 17 different countries
that
being bad is basically being this the
same thing as being low in honesty
humility wow the nail in the coffin of
the Big Five personality assessment
there okay so going back going back to
the bullying thing
um I'm very interested in the sext
differences in bullying what why do
girls bully why do boys bully and how do
they do it differently
yeah absolutely both are are bullying
for the similar sorts of things for
resources uh for reputations for
reproduction
there's a couple other potential
functions deterrence and Recreation we
can talk about but
boys and girls while they have some
different pressures both of them need to
secure resources boys more than girls
um
and both of them need to secure a
reputation in their status hierarchies
we know from primate literatures and
human literatures that high-ranking
women uh have better reproductive
success
and so both are motivated
to achieve those the biggest difference
that we find
is that boys engage in much more
physical bullying which fits with every
study on physical aggression that's
because boys have at least men have a
greater degree of variance in
reproductive outcomes
so the greatest bullies in history I
think of folks like Genghis Khan
who's father of one percent of the
world's population alive today he and
his family are the ancestors would be a
better way of saying that
um
so there's a huge incentive for boys to
take risks that isn't present in girls
so girls tend to engage in uh Less
Direct bullying so indirect verbal and
indirect social bullying but boys also
engage in a lot of that behavior too
their boys can be very strategic about
spreading rumors
um about their competitors
and what they often tend to use another
difference is the language that they use
so women tend to go after another
woman's sexual reputation and boys tend
to go after another boy's manliness I
mean just to interject the women chasing
after chess or females chasing after
Chastity and derogating that in their
Rivals and Men about Manliness
I the first time that I learned this
from through an evolutionary lens it
blew my mind because it's so plain and
obvious and everybody knows this you
know that my favorite example of this
did you see that uh Greta turnberg got
into a spot with Andrew Tate like three
months ago on Twitter so Andrew was
saying I'm gonna drive my supercars and
I'm gonna emit CO2 and [__] you Greta
like you're an idiot uh and she quote
tweeted him I think it's like
it's like the one of the most liked
tweets of all time now I think she's got
two of the top ten I'm pretty sure
they're both Andrew Tate and um she
accused him of small dick energy
and I thought okay okay anybody that
needs a massive social experiment
showing what people think men value the
most small dick energy what are you
derogating that you're derogating
manliness you're derogating
formidability there's a little bit of
sort of sexual prowess in there reducing
status down if he'd replied and he was
on the streets of Newcastle outside of a
nightclub at three in the morning having
had a couple of too many beers he would
have said something like [__] you you
slag like because again what is that
that is
a derogation of Chastity uh one of the
brutal things I learned about this over
the last couple of months is that
um this from Tanya Reynolds she said
that derogating Chastity is such a
Precision engineered weapon because it's
almost impossible to disprove you can't
walk around showing people how little
sex you're having like look at all of
this sex that I'm not doing look at how
pure I am it's basically impossible so
it's a real Precision engineered strike
I just love I love that uh sex
difference in terms of what gets
targeted and the fact that that shows up
in bullying isn't surprising
yeah absolutely uh you know particularly
since these kids have average or better
social skills they didn't become the
captain of the football team or the head
cheerleader through physical prowess
alone in most cases it's because they
know how to manipulate these socials
cues so they really know how to hit kids
where it hurts but that's
individualistic you know one of my
I don't say favorite because against the
wrong connotation but one of the more
powerful or interesting stories I heard
was about Lou Ferrigno uh a bodybuilder
who for listeners who don't know play
The Incredible Hulk without any CGI or
makeup that just painted him green huge
man full of muscles and he was
relentlessly bullied because he has a
hearing loss so kids would make fun of
the way you talk and that's not
something you can punch your way out of
if people are causing calling you stupid
or slow
punching them
doesn't change that
and so
bullies are really effective at
picking the
impact that's going to hurt their target
the most because it sends the strongest
signal right you're saying to number one
and three look what I did to the
reputation of 17. we all know she didn't
sleep around yeah she messed around with
this one guy but I destroyed your
reputation you mess with me it's gonna
happen to you
does this mean that bullies are smarter
on average
the data on IQ shows that they are
average so they're not necessarily
smarter or uh or
more cunning I think the biggest
difference comes in the low honesty
humility means they're willing to use
these things I mean I'm sure you know
hang out with your friends
a lot of soft spots that you can hurt
them with the difference is you don't
you don't go there you make fun of the
things that you know they'll laugh at
but you don't talk about that one thing
that would really hurt them and Bullies
do
I'm trying to map this onto my
experience so for a little bit of
background I was pretty badly bullied
throughout school and I haven't really
spoken about it much on the podcast but
then I did this big episode a couple of
months ago and I felt like okay now's
the time for me to really start to
open up about what I felt and I got this
really uh heartfelt message from a guy
who used to bully me in school and he'd
seen this interview I'd done with the
BBC and he had to reach out and
apologize very like super super moving
and I'm trying to think back to my
experience as much as I've probably
tried to shove bits of it away uh trying
to think back to my experience and and
map myself onto the lessons that you're
teaching us here and um the honesty
humility thing
I find myself being uh quite orderly I
don't break rules very much
um and I think that that like procedural
classic British stand in a line follow
the the rules and procedures thing I
think that's that's definitely something
that I've got in me quite strongly I
don't tend to break rules very much I
have a massive amount of guilt and shame
when I do stuff I do feel like pretty
bad about
[__] people over if I say something
that's mean that I know has probably
heard someone who maybe even hasn't
heard them but I'll worry about whether
or not it has so that's in there and
then when you were talking about
um
the the bullies not using that and and
being able to kind of uh Precision
strike derogate uh I was
smaller
um when I was in school even though I'm
a little bigger now uh would have been
not Dumber I would have been probably
smart or Smarter on average than um most
of the kids certainly most of the kids
that were bullying me but significantly
less socially Adept so I think
high scores a lot of the time like let's
say that I outperformed a bunch of the
bullies in in a test or got higher
grades or was moved up a class or or did
whatever
um that would become also a
justification for uh bullying down the
line so yeah I think that um
to like trying to map what I've learned
from you onto my experience in school I
think I really had kind of a perfect
storm of a lack of physical
formidability and some pretty high
social isolation coupled with lack of
social capability uh that just made me
like an absolute perfect Target
yeah and there's a number of things to
dive into there but I think the first
and most important is victims
recognizing that it's not their fault uh
bullies are going through it's it's
almost like you know the Terminator
walking with this little scanning list
saying who's a good Target who's a good
Target there's the right target it's not
something that you did there are
sometimes uh victims that we call
provocative victims who are sometimes
bully victims themselves and I should
qualify now that when I'm talking about
bullies I'm talking about kids who are
primarily bullies and not victims as
well kids who are both bullies and
victims they're like the Nelson months
as they have bad social skills they've
disregulated uh Etc how common are they
yeah I was just gonna say they don't do
most of the bullying uh estimates are
less than 30 percent uh 70 to 80 of the
bullies is bullying that's done is done
by the really dominant kids
and so they're picking in a very
cowardly way
uh somebody that can't effectively fight
back the kids were picking on Lou
Ferrigno might have been smaller but
they knew that he couldn't respond
without you know looking more socially
awkward the only way he can defend
himself is by punching his this guy's no
social skills so it's a very
callous very calculated predatory way of
achieving what you want
whereas on the opposite end if you're
high in honesty humility you have what
you said You Believe In fairness you
know I've seen some of your interviews
you try and present a balanced view
um you don't take advantage of people uh
when the opportunity presents itself
and and that's so much more important
than we often hear that it's an anger
issue or a lack of emotional empathy and
those really aren't strongly correlated
at all with bullying especially
emotional empathy
um and if you look at almost any action
hero that's been in Hollywood
from the 80s onward right even before
that Clint Eastwood they all have the
profile of they're very low in
emotionality and empathy they're very
low in agreeableness but they're high in
honesty humility these are good people
until you piss them off yeah they've got
that Noble side to them right right and
it's that nobility that's why we like
them uh in the sense that yes you think
of John Wick how many people you've
killed in this series such as dog don't
touch his [__] dog that's the lesson
but we still like him because he's
honorable and he has that sense with him
and that
um is really the biggest cost that we
found for bullying is that while they
are very good at getting what we call
dominance or popularity
people don't like them
and that's because people can recognize
what they're doing so the head
cheerleader
um is intimidating the captain of the
football team's intimidating but you
don't really want to spend a lot of time
with them unless you're directly gaining
from their power yeah and we trickle
down effect of whatever good sort of
social Halo they've got going on okay so
what about the ages of bullying what age
does bullying Peak is there a difference
you already mentioned physicality kind
of adjusts over time but what about if
we roll forward from school into
adulthood the workplace the the
neighborhood Etc
so we
had Jamie ostrov in uh Buffalo
studies actually bullying in the
preschool so we know that uh it exists
early on and some other colleagues have
shown that babies might have a basic
understanding of power imbalances and
interactions
so it probably starts pretty early we
know that in Children and adolescents it
Peaks right around the age of 13 to 14.
and the data isn't 100 lined up whether
that's because when you you're usually
transitioning schools and so you have to
reassert yourself or whether it's
because of puberty but most of the
evidence is coming down on the side of
puberty that once the mating game starts
bullying kicks up another gear that
there's a whole new level of seriousness
which means between the ages about 13 to
15 is when bullying Peaks
it decreases
but it does continue on into adulthood
being a bully in uh high school or
Elementary School is predictive of being
a bullying in the workplace almost
certainly in my opinion because the
shared underlying traits of honest and
humility which
for different but similar reasons are
also the their lowest in adolescence it
looks like that's when we bottom out an
honesty humility it's a time when you
separate from your family and start
thinking about yourselves
so it could explain why somebody like
the the individual you mentioned
was a jerk then and it isn't a jerk
later now that they've grown up a little
but there are many jerks who persist
into adulthood and are happy to continue
bullying people throughout adulthood
so childhood bullying is predictive of
adult bullying as well some people will
age out of it but not everybody will
dude I I have to say one of the things
that
okay before I say that is there any
correlation that you have found between
the family socioeconomic status the
presence of a father in the home race
differences
[Music]
um
uh like a family environment stuff like
that I'm trying to separate out you know
the this honesty humility thing from
some of the more environmental factors
yeah so
um father in the home we've looked at
briefly
um and I've done other work say on
pubertal maturation a father in their
home that I think shoots down that
hypothesis even though I kind of backed
it up in the past
um
bad neighborhoods and competitive
environments exacerbate bullying what's
a competitive environment
so where people endorse competitive
attitudes
um that status really matters winning is
more important than having fun things
like that
um that increases bullying uh having
role models who bully uh increases
bullying there's a really
interesting study that was done by some
colleagues in um I believe it was North
Carolina uh and North Carolina is a
purple State and in 2016 they did a
study in 2015 and 2017. and in the
districts that went hard red for Trump
um a year after so from 2015 to 2017
there was an increase in racialized
bullying uh in those districts which
why and only those districts our
assumption is They're copying their role
model
um and what their role model is doing uh
so Role Models matter the really
interesting thing about SCS which
typically you know being poor is
associated with risk factors
not bullying it's the opposite wealthier
kids are more likely to be bullies and
the reason for that is because they have
power
if you're the kid who has uh the best
clothes and you just came back from
Europe
and kids can come over to your house and
go you know jet skiing uh at your
cottage then you have a lot of power
that you can use over kids who don't
have that so we actually see that higher
SES is a risk factor for bullying right
so I'm just trying to think that
the kids who have more that are higher
in socioeconomic status
that have more resources at home
this isn't necessarily due to the fact
that the
lessons and worldview that they have is
I can do things and not have
repercussions it is more that they are
given this Baseline of just higher
status and from this higher status it
means that there is a a greater number
of people to punch down on that's kind
of an interesting way to do it so I've
got it in my head you know that famous
graph the hypergamy graph of sort of
mandating across but then women only
kind of dating up I'm kind of seeing the
same thing but for bullying where you
know number one can bully everybody down
but number five can only Bully from
number five down and number ten can only
believe from number 10 down it's very
difficult to bully up
um so the people that are higher up in
terms of socioeconomic status have a
larger pool of other people from which
to bully
yeah I I also suspect that you're right
uh that some of it Although our early
analysis don't suggest that we're doing
more refined analysis I think some of it
is going to come from the parents wealth
is correlated with the same sort of
arrogant attitudes of uh winner take all
uh High conversations yes first place
and then there's losers to balance out
our samples for example when we work
with undergraduates we always get
students from the business school
because they're habitually lower in
honesty humility because it's a
Cutthroat World in business right it's
Doggy Dog Winner Takes all so some of
that is certainly trickling down from
parents but one of the really
interesting studies we did was showing
that
um
maternal monitoring and maternal just
because women are an average primary
caregivers but you can take caregiver
monitoring uh
is associated with a reduction in
bullying
but then we split that between kids who
are high in honesty humility and kids
who are low and honestly humility kids
who are high in honesty humility it
didn't make any difference at all they
are always low in bullying so if you're
a good sensible kid doesn't really
matter uh what your parents are doing or
monitoring you because you're not going
to be tempted to take advantage of other
kids it was when the kids were low in
honesty humility themselves
and of course there's going to be shared
genetic and environmental influences
from the parents along those lines but
for kids who were low in honesty
humility and whose parents didn't watch
them then they were the ones who by far
engaged in the most bullying what do you
think is happening there just a lack of
supervision and a disposition that tends
you towards being like breaking rules
and social norms and stuff without the
parent there you're more likely to
succumb to your base instincts yeah
exactly
um and it's also potentially
you know if you want to be Macy's alien
about it might be
more sensible for the parents to suggest
uh
more subtle ways of gaining power
because bullying can still especially in
some Modern environments land you in
trouble yeah schools have very poor
records in general in dealing with
bullying
um but I think that's really what's
underlying it is that uh you know
without parents there to guide the child
those instincts are kicking in say okay
go for the throat
um they do just to reiterate what you
said earlier on fatherless homes you
haven't managed to find a particularly
strong correlation
no uh single parents single parenting
doesn't seem to be a major predictor
again probably because
uh if the cause of the single home isn't
honestly humility stress in and of
itself isn't going to make a a good
person turn that
um we do tend to see
uh what's the conscientiousness if that
gets lower then yes you engage in more
risk-taking Behavior but that
risk-taking behavior doesn't turn in a
dark Direction unless you have the dark
predispositions so if you get a once you
start loading up all kinds of different
factors yeah yeah yeah it's so
interwoven man it's so interesting I
love it I love how how
um
complex it is it it really does seem
though you know that as with everything
behavioral genetics comes and smashes
all of your ideas in the face but I
think just you've got a lot of raw
materials and you have a disposition and
there are things that you can do to kind
of nudge it around but
really you kind of are the way you are
um
there was something that you said before
first off I'm realizing the reason I
probably uh didn't lose my virginity
until the age of 17 is because I got
bullied in school which I don't know
whether that's an advantage or a
disadvantage to have an extra year under
my belt before I decided to have sex
um the relationship between alcohol use
and bullying was something that I
thought was super super interesting
especially coming from the UK a country
where the uh age of legal age for
drinking is 18 as opposed to 21.
yeah it's a great question
um and the answer is with everything
it's complicated
um so for example kids in China
um
these other major predictor and Chinese
bullying is uh conscientiousness so
willingness to plan ahead think long
term versus uh being impulsive lazy Etc
that doesn't show up in North American
data and we think that's because in
China where many schools have in local
parentists which means they can act like
parents the punishments for bullying are
much more severe so if a kid is caught
bullying uh they have the power to
physically discipline the child toss the
child out of class uh expel you're
kidding me you can get spanked in China
still
yep uh yeah I'm not going to say I know
every school in China it's a big country
but in the schools we work with yes
um
in North America
we tend to find it's low agreeableness
being angry is associated with it
probably because it's not as risky a
behavior so you it's not showing up with
just these really impulsive kids
having said that
alcohol is associated with an increase
in all kinds of anti-sociality because
it releases impulsivity so I'd expect to
be a bigger effect in China than it
would be in North America or in the UK
but I would suspect that alcohol use
would both increase bullying directly as
well as correlate with the general
pattern of anti-sociality
you're also going to have probably the
people who do start drinking sooner will
have a social group very few 15 16 17
year olds are drinking in the house on
their own uh it's you're part of a group
that means if you are part of a group
you've probably got status that means
that you have this let's call it
um like the bullying pool uh The
Bullying pool has been opened up for you
a little bit uh I also I you know to
fold another thing into the Chinese
discussion Asian people suck at drinking
like Asian people are not good at
drinking and you know that that may be
another sort of racial difference one
other thing I forgot to ask you about
the the family setup
um I'm going to guess that only children
are more likely to be bullied than
children that have got brothers or
sisters and or cousins that live in the
neighborhood or go to the same school
yeah I would have thought the same thing
but the date on that is is ambiguous
um and I think that's partly because uh
data shows that being bullied at home is
correlated with being bullied at school
and so if your older brother or sister
and sibling bullying uh is a newer area
of research it's not my area of research
but what's been done seems to show that
it's as toxic as being bullied by
strangers
um so if your older brother or sister is
picking on you
that a might carry over into school
and be your behavior and reaction to
other kids might carry over to school
making you a a more appealing victim
[Music]
so it's not the protective factor that
we thought
um in that I'm sure it is in some cases
if you've got a good older brother or
sister who looks mediated by what the
relationship with the siblings is like
yeah so he double-edged I guess is the
short way of saying it having siblings
in so many other categories with
bullying it's a double-edged sword is
bullying so okay so getting into the
sort of more ancestral reasons we've
spoken about kind of I guess the school
yard mostly
um
I'm gonna guess that bullying must have
been used ancestrally to Foster social
cohesion in one form or another uh what
else that and then what else was it used
for
similar things getting resources so you
want that piece of need a lot of
hunter-gatherers divide their meat
equally well you bullied people to
giving your family better meat or more
meat
um you bully the people across Hills not
to come and hunt in your territory even
though you go into theirs on occasion uh
you
interrogate the reputations of
competitors uh especially in adolescence
when you're you're getting ready to
enter that dating pool okay you don't
want to be with her she's she's not
faithful
um
interestingly one of you know one of the
things that really tuned me into the
evolutionary research is a book by Jean
Briggs never in anger and it's a book
about her life with the labrador Inuit
the Eskimo was I don't know what inuitar
and they have a social Norm that you're
not allowed to express anger which is
probably really useful if you know
you're living in an igloo and it's minus
40 and if somebody gets pissed and you
break the wall everybody freeze to death
so you're not allowed to get angry but
they still bullied
um there was a main group of people who
stuck together and there was a smaller
group and the main group would make fun
of uh the smaller group uh talk about
how stingy they were they didn't share
um they weren't as social or friendly
and then the main group had a bit of a
food shortage and had to rely on the
weaker group right flip things around
and there's some really interesting
Dynamics but there's a case where that
group versus group
theme which is a really really powerful
driver of human behavior uh it is very
easy to turn one group against another
which is something we're looking at in
adolescence
it's trickier to do but we're really
interested in seeing what happens when
two groups start bullying each other's
weaker members
um
my guess is that either
Fades away or very quickly escalates
talk to me about how social media has
changed the landscape of bullying
yeah social media uh I'm really not a
fan of
you know I heard somebody describe it
well it was Max tegman um that it's our
first experiment with AI uh interfering
with our lives and it did not go well
um the algorithms that it uses are not
friendly
um so there's a number of impacts the
first and most obvious is that it's made
it really hard to track down uh bullies
and when I talk to the school principals
at the schools that we work with some
fantastic schools here in the Niagara
region
the principals tell me how difficult it
is when one of their students is being
bullied but it's being done online
so what Authority does the principal
have to you know shut down an Instagram
account or it's really done on Twitter
but you know Snapchat or uh Tick Tock
wherever it is
it makes it much easier to bully without
having repercussions which means it's
an attractive option
fortunately
the data shows that the kids who bully
the most online or the same kids who are
bullying in person so it hasn't
encouraged these kids who I would say
are probably not low in honesty humility
to suddenly start taking up bullying but
it has made it much harder for us to
prevent
uh
cases of bullying where the bullies are
smart enough and it's not a giant week
of intelligence to say okay if I hit
this make an anonymous account yeah
exactly there's nothing that they can do
compared to if you know slam a kid into
a locker uh in front of the teacher and
so that aspect has certainly been very
toxic
the General Dynamics of uh
social media
are especially for girls toxic it's not
my area of specialty but one of the
interesting things we found looking at
uh data from pre to post pandemic is
that girls suffered a higher decline in
mental health than boys
um and we think part of that is because
of how much time they spend on social
media and we know young boys in social
media I can see it in my sons they do
the same sort of thing that we did when
we were little you know play video games
with their friends uh they're yelling at
each other are you idiot when you do
that you know no you shot me you picked
up my health pack but it's the same sort
of thing they'd probably be doing if
they're in the room together
we'll spend a lot more time doing social
comparison
um and those algorithms don't show you a
balanced view of Life they show the
worst or the best
um you know the most sensationalized
views which
makes girls more vulnerable to the
flexibility
as victims you know you're not just
comparing yourself to the best looking
girl at school you're comparing yourself
to the best looking girls on the
internet which is
not a fair or smart comparison to be
making
and the kind of media that they use
is more conducive to that kind of
bullying than it is in the social media
that boys tend to use
yeah it's a I had gene twangy on the
show recently lady that wrote igen and
new book Generations
and it's not good man it's like what is
it 60 of teenage girls say that they
have persistent or regular feelings of
hopelessness it's like it's just such a
dark statistic and um yeah I
the weird thing is that it's such a high
number of girls unless you're saying
that 60 of the girls are being bullied
by 40 of the girls which you know I
wouldn't imagine that 40 of all girls
are bullies especially not up against
this other group it's just like a an
ambient uh
permeated
displeasure that everybody feels it's
it's it's not done by somebody it's it's
baked into the code and the experience
of the technology itself which makes it
you know even worse at least you could
do an intervention with the individuals
if it was coming from individuals but if
it's coming from the medium that you
exist in that's even harder
um looking at
modern civilization then School we've
spoken about an awful lot today
compared to an ancestral lifestyle have
we created an environment which is more
conducive to bullying is school a
perfect storm for bullying
yes and no
um it's well certainly yes uh one of the
things that mediates bullying and Peter
gray wrote a really nice series of
articles about this is uh you have mixed
aged and often mixed sex play in
hunter-gatherer groups because for most
times of the year almost all
hunter-gatherers live in small bands in
about 20 to 25 and then seasonally when
times are good they get together with
the extended family 100 150 for a few
months
so most of the time you only have in a
say half the group or kids you've got 12
kids to pick from so it's harder to
um
have these isolated cliques everybody
sort of has to get along
and the mix-age play reduces the need to
show off the 12 year old doesn't need to
show that they're better than their
eight-year-old cousin right that's it's
a given and the the 12 year old boy
isn't as motivated to compete against a
12 year old girl right so because each
cohort that would be competing for
status and is sufficiently similar in
status for bullying to be a useful tool
is so small
there is basically no point in but
there's one person from this age and
this age and this age and this age at
each gender
and that's it
right and on top of that most of them
are going to be related uh so that's uh
kin selection so that's a break on
attacking copies in your genes and other
bodies
so those are reasons why I think modern
society
and in particular as well you'd have
adults who'd step in and are motivated
to step in and we know that one of the
big factors that motivates teachers is
whether they feel a motivated be
confident in intervening whereas in the
past you know you'd be living with your
aunts and uncles and they would have no
problem saying knock that off
um
in large part because that sort of
behavior is rarely tolerated
the downside to ancestral environments
is that the stakes could be potentially
higher so if you and I were siblings and
there's one piece of meat
um
yes you have 50 of my genes but I have a
hundred percent so unless I'm saving two
of my brothers I should be bullying to
get that need and so the competition in
that sense could be life or death
which would increase the benefit of
engaging in bullying so my guess is that
bullying is probably less common in the
past
but when it did happen it had the
potential to become very serious
I want to talk about some interventions
and stuff now so you mentioned that one
of the challenges that teachers face on
and so forth there's a quote from you
which I really liked which was bullying
is neither innate nor learned but it is
the interaction between two natural
predispositions selfless versus selfish
and our individual environments the
households we grow up in for instance
promote or hinder these predispositions
that's why it's possible to reduce
bullying but challenging to do so what
have you learned about
interventions that work what is bad uh
what what is bad what is good where do
teachers struggle where do parents
struggle Etc
yeah that's you know in some ways the
million dollar question and when I tell
my students about development
um the two things I tell them in the big
class that I teach on development is
number one we don't have brains this big
to find food and avoid Predators we have
brains as big to figure out how to
interact and compete against other
brains this big it's the only reason we
have big brains so it's going to be
complicated number one and number two
development is never nature versus
nurture it's always the combination of
the two so what's more important than
making a chocolate chip cookie having
chocolate chips or having an oven right
the nature ingredients or the
environment you need both right and
every child is the product of both so I
don't believe in pure determinism either
from the environments or genetics having
said that you know some kids are going
to come with different ingredients some
kids are going to be uh
having different previous positions and
some kids are obviously are going to
come from different uh ovens different
environments and so some of the things
that we've seen
are that purely social interventions
where we rely on kids uh just plain
learning don't work and my favorite
example of that was uh in Norway where
the father of bullying research Daniel
Vayas integrated a huge program where
every level of government from federal
to whatever the version of provincial or
state is the city to schools to parents
all got in and everybody cracked down on
Bully and they reduced bullying by
something like 30 to 40 percent one of
the biggest reductions we've seen at a
large scale ever
that worked really well for three years
and then what did the government do is
expensive so the government said hey
this problem's done
stop spending money on it
and bullying shot right back up to
normal which is a really strong argument
against it being learned because if this
was a learn purely learned behavior kids
would have seen low levels of bullying
for years and they would have just stuck
with that behavior
the fact that popped back up
suggests that it's really this cost
benefit
um so that's where the better programs
are aimed at so one of the more widely
distributed ones and then I'll talk
about the one that that we're promoting
um is Kiva uh done by Christina Salman
Ali and some other Finnish folk that's
now gone across the world and it relies
on peers to knock down bullying say this
isn't cool it's not effective uh we're
not going to give you status and
popularity and it knocks down bullying
by about 20 25 percent
really interestingly though they found
that it only works on low and medium
popularity bullies probably a lot of the
bully victims when the bullies are high
in popularity their peers don't impact
them which makes sense the popular kids
aren't going to listen to what
you know a group of well-meaning
empathic uh you know mid popularity kids
are telling them
and the problem is most bullying is done
by really popular kids
so
it's very hard to change peer behavior
when the leaders of the peers are the
ones who are doing the behavior
so that's a limitation of peer-based
interventions
we've tried something called the
meaningful roles which is an attempt to
try and give
uh students some way of meeting their
goals that they want the predispositions
so that kid who's low in honesty
humility is arrogant wants attention
wants to be at the top
find a way of a keeping them busy so
they're not able to believe that they
don't have the time but also be that
they're able to meet that goal and so
one of the things that we do is we
assign a variety of jobs to different
people in the class and we think that
being the Walmart door greeter is not a
high status thing but if you're you know
a 13 year old in grade eight and
everybody who comes into class you say
hi welcome to Mrs Smith's grade a class
and they have to say hi back you're
getting a lot of social Spotlight on you
right a lot of attention and so in a way
you're getting that status and
visibility that you want in a pro-social
way
and we found that reduces overall School
Violence by 70 percent
so
you're giving
them a way of getting what they want
without harming others now some people
say is is that rewarding beliefs and
that's that's a tricky thing because in
a way we are
but the hope is that over time and we
know personality isn't fixed either
personality is a previous position not a
destiny that they start shifting towards
a more pro-social way realizing hey I
can I can get what I want
and still be kind to others
and I think we really need that
combination of the carrot of the stick
because overall bullying interventions
have largely failed miserably it's a
very hard Behavior to get rid of
which suggests we need these really
multi-pronged
multimodal
interventions and of course it doesn't
help that in the adult world kids see
all kinds of examples of people getting
away with bullying and getting great
things you know Donald Trump whatever
you whether you like him or not I think
he's a fantastic example of a bully
who's been very successful he's got
millions if not billions of dollars uh
married three supermodels six kids uh
and reputation and dominance became the
president of the United States and he
ticked the boxes for how being
aggressive and kicking down can work
and he's not the only one there's lots
of celebrities in sports in uh in Media
that show that being mean can work
and so even if we have a perfect School
intervention if kids are learning that
okay once you hit Wall Street you have
to be ruthless
tear out other people's throats once
they see their parents playing in their
Sports league and you know
stomping on their competition and or
cheating on their taxes
doing whatever they can to get ahead
kids are going to copy that so it's a
really
difficult Behavior to get rid of because
there's not only genetic predispositions
but there's so many examples in the
environment of
how being a bully can be effective
have you been able to track whether or
not bullying has increased
longitudinally because I would throw
signs my way into saying that
because we see in popular media now
at least on the surface more dark Triad
adjacent type Behavior people being
backbiting reality television that kind
of trend of like
proximal like ancillary to psychopathy
machiavellianism manipulative type stuff
um that that would have trickled down to
more young people seeing that as a path
to success is that something you've seen
is it trending up is it trending down
in Canada uh the data that I'm aware of
and these are data from tens of
thousands of kids
um
over the last 20 years despite bullying
interventions at every school and lots
of those bullying awareness days or pink
shirt day Etc so lots of interventions
the number of people who say that they
bully others has decreased by 20 percent
the number of kids who say that they've
been victimized hasn't changed at all
and I think that's because of these
opposing forces that you know we are
trying to make inroads
kids today are more empathic uh it's a
really neat study I just read that over
the last 50 years people have become
more generous in economic games and
prisoners dilemmas so there's an
argument to be made that we're more
Cooperative than we were 50 60 years ago
in general
but there's also many of these examples
of these hyper-competitive individuals
and hyper-competitive media
uh incentives
that are still
creating a lane for kids who think that
they can really do well by bullying
others is the implication there that the
number of bullies has reduced or the
number of people who say that they bully
has reduced
we don't know
um it's a great question little bastards
that they are
you know one of the things that I often
hear is you're studying honesty humility
and how do you expect people who are low
and honesty to do self-reports
appropriately yeah yeah get [__] Tony
but they they admit to a lot of stuff uh
you'll have once you give anonymity uh
they'll admit to bullying they'll admit
to Dating Violence uh if we don't do it
in the high schools but if you go into
universities they'll admit to rape abuse
they'll admit to serious stuff if it's
Anonymous
um if you made them stand up in front of
the class don't everybody put your hand
up that's been a raper this year yeah I
imagine that that's that's not exactly
going to happen very commonly
um what about
for
we
does punishment work like are there any
punishments that work to disincentivize
bullies forgetting Rehabilitation just
simply encouraging them to stop doing it
does anything work
yeah but I've always said it's a cost
benefit behavior
um and that these kids are behaving
rationally or you know adaptively
um and so if you increase the cost uh it
makes you less likely to do the behavior
we know that the very best defense
against bullying is retaliation fighting
back we also know that the very worst
thing for escalating bullying is
fighting back it's double-edged in that
if you are able to deter the bully and
they say like okay geez this is too
tougher than that to crack then they'll
find somebody else but if you do it in a
way that say shows up the bully well
then they have to give up everything
they got or they double down and they
double down and it gets much worse
so direct retaliation which is what most
people kids and adults say to do
is very risky it's high risk High reward
the study in the in Norway shows that if
everybody clamps down you can reduce
bullying but you're if you only focus on
the negatives you know I joke with the
school board and with my colleagues that
I used to be invited to lots of schools
to talk about bullying but now that my
message is uh bullying will get you sex
power popularity and resources and this
is the next bit and we have a hard time
catching you and Prosecuting you so
please don't do it right I don't get
invited to a lot of schools anymore
which is the other part of it it's
really hard to find them
um
that same BBC Style video uh documentary
of these kids filming them in the
schoolyard
showed that adults were present only 20
of the time so kids know not to do it in
front of adults
and 10 of the time or sorry half the
time that it was there so
10 of total 50 of the time an adult was
there the adult did nothing about it
um so kids know that adults are going to
miss a lot of this is there an element
is there an element there that when the
adult is around
there's a selection bias that the kid
who is doing the bullying is more likely
to be the one that's maybe a bit
likeable they're probably socially a
little bit more Adept the kid that is
being picked on is the one that's maybe
a bit less likable they're a bit weird
the adult doesn't really feel as much of
an affinity how much does that
contribute do you think
huge uh and we've done some informal
studies on this I've never had the time
to sit down and do a formal study but I
guarantee well I should say a guarantee
I'm very confident that The Stereotype
of a bully of being lonely poor
self-esteem uh bad social skills came
from school teachers and principals
catching the bully victims you know
these kids who really do come from a
broken home have bad social skills and
they solve everything with their fists
right yeah but whereas the kids who come
from those affluent homes who are
heading up the it could be the chess
club or the cheerleading team who are
really popular in the class have good
social skills
uh they don't get caught and when they
do they say oh we were just kidding
we're teasing we're so sorry you know
we'd never do that we're sorry and you
know that Jonathan's always been a
little bit weird so he's he just doesn't
really understand what's going on yeah
exactly
so
it is absolutely skewed by that and not
to mention that their parents are more
likely to be wealthy which means more
likely to make a fuss and their parents
probably have the kind of personality
that that would be likely to make a fuss
rather than say to their kid okay I'm
gonna uh take this seriously
yeah it's a difficult one eh
um trying to
trying to pass apart all of that again
you know I I'm always gonna have a soft
spot for the bully for the victim of the
bullying uh because that was me for a
long time especially the person that
would have been super socially inept
that would have been
catastrophically unlikable to probably
most of the adults that were around me
because I was just struggling to do the
social thing and I can remember a time
there was this one time during drama
class and I hadn't I'd done my homework
and one of the bullies hadn't done his
and he snatched mine off me and said
that he was gonna hand it in as his and
then need me in the head and then I was
upset because I just got knead in the
head and I got sent out of the class
because I was making a fuss and he'd
managed to not only take my homework but
also worm his way into the Drama teacher
sending me away so yeah I think it's
such a double-edged sword that lack of
um
like social capacity as a young kid
because not only does it make you more
vulnerable and likely to being a victim
of bullying it makes you less Adept at
being able to explain to the people in
power what's happening it makes you less
believable there's probably less
sympathy generally that's just being
pushed your way because you don't have
those those sorts of skills
um you mentioned before about this
double-edged sword of fighting back it's
both the best and the worst uh response
that you can give
in what ways can fighting back be done
in a manner which will make it more
likely to be a good response and less
likely to be a bad response
best thing to do is to recognize that
this is a cowardly unfair fight like
this isn't two guys you know
squaring off in the Octagon in in a
sanctioned fight to see who's toughest
this is an MMA fighter picking on some
guy on the street and doesn't even know
what's happening and the MMA fighters
got five bodies behind him so bringing
in support changing the power imbalance
by bringing in adults bringing in
friends uh
you change it to an arena where you have
some power
and preferably do it privately I
wouldn't advise kids to fight back but
if you're gonna do it don't do it
publicly I mean I've written a couple
articles uh or opinions op-eds on Putin
now he looks just like a schoolyard
bully and the problem he has is the same
as schoolyard bullies if he backs down
now
he loses a ton of his credit because
it's such a public
audience that's watching right obviously
it's okay so if you were to fight the
bully in the schoolyard or your kid was
to fight the bully in the schoolyard in
front of everybody else it's not even
though you might think you know you
could bro psychology your way into
believing that sends a message to him
and his [__] friends that they
shouldn't do it again but what you've
done is you've caused that bully to lose
a ton of status in front of the people
that are the most important whereas if
you're to see him on the walk home if
this if a physical intervention or
whatever like standing up to him is
going to happen doing it where they're
not going to lose face is actually a
much more effective way to do it because
it may be a final full stop that they
can bow out of
uh whilst being relatively Costless to
them
yeah exactly and you know it's one of
the ironic things that uh people who are
low in agreeableness I'm a little low in
agreeableness uh as my whole family is
the joke was don't poke a folk
um
we make and I sense probably there's a
little bit of that new uh because these
These are the kind of people who are
high in h which isn't humble of me to
say but low in a make good Crusaders you
know the people who stand up for other
people who don't tolerate Injustice do
not put up with people taking advantage
of others
but we've seen from victims uh in
schools victims in workplaces and
whistleblowers that that often blows
back against the person who's reacting
back right so they'll say like why is he
flipping out but the other person's
really calm Tony or Chris is really
upset well he's upset because he got
meat in the head right or Tony's upset
because this person was bullying a
graduate student Tony didn't didn't like
it but all they see is one of us yelling
and that's one of the skills that
bullies have is very quickly pivoting so
it looks like the person fighting back
is the one who's the aggressive one
they're being unreasonable you can see
how unreasonable they're being okay so
what would you say to parents let's say
that there is a parent listening whose
kid is either or first a bully and
second being bullied what are your best
piece of advice for them
yeah first for the parent whose kid is
being a bully
um they're being a coward
they're engaging in the behavior that is
going to likely keep happening in life
so they'll behave this way with their
siblings they'll behave this way with
you when you get older and you're
elderly they'll behave this way in the
workplace they'll behave this way if
their spouse they'll behave this way
with this kid so if you don't want to
live around a belief for the rest of
your life step in an interview and you
know recognizing that 20 of kids do this
mean it's not these kids aren't
Psychopaths you know your kid is not
irredeemable or uh you know going down a
difficult path and I don't want to say
that all psychopaths are irredeemable
but I'm just trying to not catastrophize
it but take it very seriously if you
have any kind of sense of fairness and
ethics your kid is breaking the rules
and you can't let them do that
for and don't buy their excuses right
that's that'd be the other thing that
we've been saying which I think parents
would have begotten is
if your kid is willing to believe
they're probably willing to lie about it
what what what's the intervention what
do you say to your kid
it depends on the specific child and
what they're doing I'd first ask you
know what are you doing why are you
doing this do you know that there's a
power imbalance you know that this is
really weak you know this is
uh not something I support it's a
moral-based one that's aiming to change
the underlying honesty humility in the
short run we know that monitoring works
so keeping a tighter leash on them until
you have confidence that they're not
doing it is effective following up with
the teachers telling the teachers that
you know this
um and that you're happy to be contacted
if anything comes up again you know is
again ratcheting up that monitoring
system so that you're essentially making
it more costly for them to engage in
that behavior they're not going to be
believed if they say they're just
teasing they're going to get caught
they're going to get punished
and then if they do well reward them you
know as I said carrot in a stick if it's
been two three months and you
legitimately have the sense that things
have gone better then you don't have to
take them out for ice cream but praise
them uh tell them that you're proud that
they've changed they're being more
mature that's the way that good people
and good societies work
and then if your child is being
victimized and the first and most
important thing especially with
adolescents is trying to have open lines
of communication
and I've got a 20 year old a 14 and a 12
year old so I'm well aware of how
challenging it can be to uh
communicate with adolescents at times
but the more you're able to do that the
more you're likely to hear about the
victimization or see changes relating to
it which are commonly uh symptoms of
anxiety or depression that increase
and in particular desire to not go to
the place where bullying is happening to
no longer want to go to school I just
need a day off and sick Etc
uh and that's a real risk like to jump
in and get involved
because the bully has chosen this person
I I can't emphasize that enough that
almost every bully strategically chooses
a victim who can't effectively fight
back and so it's it's very rare that if
they picked on somebody who could
potentially punch their way out they
would probably bully them in a way that
if they did that
um it would be really bad so bring a
girl with him so a boy and a girl tease
the guy so what is he gonna do punch the
girl then everybody knows this guy's a
cycle and he's lost the fight so number
one lines of Communication number two
contact the school and make sure to take
it seriously
there's far too many people who think
that bullying is a Rite of Passage
and the analogy I like to use is that
conflict like exercise strengthens you
um so you know that if you exercise and
you stress your bones they get stronger
but if you have too much stress and you
break a bone that bone is never as
strong as it was when it was uh you know
hole before it was broken and the same
thing happens to the link if you have
severe bullying other researchers have
shown that it affects your immune
response for decades it affects the
expression of your genes for decades
it's not a minor thing
it's not a rite of passage and if your
child has been chosen as a victim it's
you say fight back it's because they
can't the bully is in most cases they
have found a way to prevent the victim
from doing that
so bringing allies you know with the
school uh the teachers
um if they have any friends that's
really important if they don't have a
lot of friends go out of your way to try
and help them make friends
we know that having friends doesn't
reduce uh bullying dramatically is about
10 20 but what it does do dramatically
is reduces the long-term impacts of
bullying
because if you're 13 or 14 you're 15 you
know you're a teenager and your peers
are telling you you're worthless either
directly or implicitly by bullying you
it doesn't really help to hear from Mom
and Dad say you're a fine lovely person
or your grandma or your aunt to say it
you really need to hear that from peers
and so having even just one friend cuts
the odds of serious mental health
outcomes by over 50 percent
so get involved listen to your kid and
get them support what are the potential
serious mental health outcomes from
somebody that is being bullied and it's
un not untreated but you know what I
mean
yeah it's lifelong lifelong risks of
depression and anxiety and of course
we've seen unfortunately a number of
tragic incidents that result in suicide
some of the murder suicides and school
shootings have been blamed on bullying
but we certainly know there's many more
kids who are dying on of their own hands
because they can't take it and of course
that's an area where
the internet has become particularly
pernicious or um
dangerous is because it doesn't go away
you know if
back in my day you know I went to school
in the 80s early 90s if you were bullied
at school which I really wasn't
but if you were you know you could go
home and you'd have a sanctuary from all
of that now you can't it's on your phone
it's on the message it's on the boards
and so you're putting your child in a
place
where they're fighting an unfair battle
against people who are actively trying
to hurt them I I can't
imagine as a parent anything that would
motivate me more strongly to stand up
and say you know get lost which is
ultimately why I went down this
Road of research it's really not fair to
the kids who are being picked on what
about getting your kids to do some sort
of team sport getting them involved at a
local either team sport or maybe a
boxing gym as well I guess that's
probably a pretty common response from
parents
you know anything that you can do to
help offset the anxiety and the
depression will help exercise is
fantastic and building those friendships
is really useful
Sports
I I always tell my grad students that
everything's great
these other than this shirt nothing's
black and white uh
because Sports can sometimes be a risk
and we've looked at bullying in sports
and have found that uh for girls it can
be a risk factor if you participate in
competitive Sports both in the sport and
outside and for boys it depends on the
sports and the team
our local
hockey team just had its captain and his
brother barred from the league for
bullying other players uh on the team
it's
another area that you need to be aware
of but anything it would even if it's
not a team sport if your child likes I
don't know dancing
or wants to learn to play the guitar
anything that will help alleviate that
including if necessary you know
switching schools getting away from it
if
your child is stuck in a toxic situation
where people are picking on them like
it's an episode of Orange Is the New
Black
get them out of that situation yeah
however you can here's the thing that's
interesting man so I I've seen pretty
much both ends of the status Spectrum
right so in school was probably the most
close to the most like pitiful person
there had the lowest number of friends
was smart or whatever and I was always
going to go to college in and University
but in an area that that wasn't very
very common
um and then through probably 16
17 was kind of a middling 18 19 20 very
very quickly ascended to be one of the
best known people in you know a city
that's got a million people in it by
2223 I'm doing reality TV I'm on TV all
the time then 27 I have another crack at
reality TV all through this period of
being the guy in the front door of a
nightclub and then now from doing the
show which is you know transcended to
this much more kind of
Global I get widespread type of status
um I've seen
both ends of it and and observing the
texture of my own mind especially
through this evolutionary lens is is
[__] wild like I I know what it feels
like to be so like downtrodden and
self-deprecating and and uh like lost
and alone and in not just in solitude
because Solitude is okay but in like
abandon feels like abandoned so I I
really have seen this [__] trajectory
man I'm telling you from like the
absolute bottom of the bottom of the
bottom to now you know being somebody
that's relatively well known and um
yeah it's crazy I I totally understand
how
it could impact your immune system uh
you know in girls especially
um if it's a lot of
social bullying can even mess with their
menstrual cycle it can stop them from
releasing eggs that's one of the
suggested reasons for why women have got
concealed ovulation is that it means
that although the other women can't go
and [__] with her to stop this egg from
releasing because if you did that's
basically like a big a big flag of uh
I'm fertile and you can come and mess it
up if if you come over here
um so yeah I really do
kind of see this
just how important it is
um the reason that it got me thinking
about that was I wondered whether
some sort of sense of of Mastery so the
the difference that I had or the thing
that I guess kind of ripped me out of
apart from
aging out of kids that are just brutal
and awful and being kind of pressed into
a school which is a perfect environment
somewhere between a a prison and a drama
class to to enact this
um the other thing that happened was I
gained uh competence in areas that was
valued by other people which caused me
to rise up through the status hierarchy
which meant that who's going to bully me
right like they need to get into my
nightclub or they you know they want me
to shout them out on Instagram or
whatever like I'm aware that it's not
the same as love but it's a protect it's
like a prophylactic against somebody
bullying you
because of status
um
so I wonder whether
whether it's the boxing or the playing
piano or the violin or the doing
whatever
um some sense of Mastery Downstream from
that is going to get you status now
obviously there's certain stuff that's
super lame if you learn the trombone or
something I wouldn't imagine that it's
particularly protective
um it's just like sucks as an instrument
but if you do something which is cool
um and you encourage your kids to go and
be good at a thing that was the problem
that I had as well I I was very very
good at Cricket that was my sport of
choice I played six seven nights a week
every single summer I got time off
school to go and play which obviously I
loved
um but it was a sport it was like from
the most working-class town in all of
England playing the most aristocratic
Bourgeois wanky sport that you can think
of
um so I didn't get I didn't get any
status from it it's like the rugby
players and the football players got
status the cricket people it's like who
the [__] plays Cricket there's like
three people that play cricket in this
school um so even the thing that I did
that was good my thinking being if you
can try and maybe
um reverse engineer something that's at
the intersection of your kids interests
what they like to do and also what you
could perhaps reasonably predict would
cause them to gain in a little bit of
status or whatever that might be an
interesting uh potential
pathway for them
I think that's a really good General
approach
um
for many things in life is to build on
your children's interests create
self-esteem it helps create resilience
because life is going to knock you down
whether it's bullies or otherwise and
having that reservoir uh of confidence
and self-belief is really useful and
that does come from Mastery uh
it is something that is
certainly important to transmit it helps
with that sense of self-worth so I would
absolutely endorse that the only
limitation of course is it's not doing
anything to stop the ongoing stress from
The Bullying if it's ongoing yeah it's
going to take you a while to get Mastery
at [__] playing the guitar or boxing
or whatever
and your story reminds me of a really
tragic video from that BBC you know
style filming and it's a group of girls
uh grade sixes who are standing in a
circle and they're kicking a grade five
girl on the ground just stomping the
crap out of her teacher walks by with
the little girls holding her hands in
grade twos or threes which a lot of
schoolyard teachers do you know they
play with the cute little kids
the kids are smart enough to stop so the
girl gets up and goes away
30 seconds later girl comes back
and they grab her throw to the ground
and start kicking her again and you're
thinking why in God's name would you go
back
and it's because as humans being alone
is a death sentence so she would rather
be with friends she would rather be with
enemies that were bullying her than on
her own with no one around yeah and then
the best part of it is at the end uh
some dad or something walks through just
looks and keeps walking it sees it
happens it keeps walking by
yeah I mean that's a that's a difficult
one I don't I don't have kids yet but I
can't wait to be a dad and when I am
it's gonna bring up I know that it's
going to bring up a lot of challenges
for me because my uh
the chip on my shoulder that I've worked
very hard to try and get rid of
it's gonna come back you know if I see
another kid being bullied if I find out
that my child either is a victim or is
doing it
I'm not going to be as impartial and as
rational and as balanced as I should be
uh and that's I know it's like a I know
seeing a tsunami on the on the horizon
because every kid I would imagine that
some ungodly
proportion of children will encounter
some form of bullying at some point in
their in that time in school
80 of kids uh encounter some form of
bullying okay
um
so yeah and you know you're gonna find
out about this and I'm I'm gonna have
this you know a good bit of self work
and and a good bit of personal
development really be tested it's gonna
stress test just whether a thousand
sessions of meditation has made a
difference or not because I'm gonna be
like well [__] here I am I'm 12 years
old again and I Hate My Life
um
yeah that's here's the other thing as
well that I've taken away I mean you
know I found your work absolutely
fascinating an evolutionary lens for
such a common problem which is so
formative on people's lives I think is
is just phenomenal
um
the other thing that I've taken away and
this may be
legitimate part of the chip on my
shoulder that I always had I always used
to be resentful of the kids that were
bullies because
they felt it felt like they were given
an extra degree of an excuse for their
behavior from the teachers that I was
never given that the teachers almost saw
the uh propensity this disposition that
the kids had that were being mean and I
could get my homework stolen a need in
the head and drama class and now we get
sent to the Head teacher but if I was
talking a little bit too loudly in class
I would also be punished and I remember
thinking at the time like
this just feels so unfair it feels so
unfair that I'm given less sympathy and
also held to a higher standard and I've
always always hated absolutely ardently
hated
using excuses like well you know he
comes from a broken home or well you
know she's she's she's going through a
rough time of it at the moment and
you know I I would have had to swallow
it had your data set otherwise but with
this it's no
it is very much a conscious Choice which
is only mildly influenced by the
environment that the person is in you
know if this kid decides to enact
bullying it is a conscious choice and it
is not them
calling out for help it is not them
enacting rage from inside of the house
it's them trying to gain [__] status
they want to climb the social ladder in
the same way as schmoozing and taking
your client out for a dinner in 20 years
time is going to be the same they're
just doing this and that makes it it
makes it so much more Machiavellian it
makes it so much less desperate
um and uh yeah it gives me
it's annoying but vindicating because at
least it makes me kind of feel like the
presupposition that I had as a kid uh
was somewhat accurate
yeah and you know I would say that
if you're looking for a little sound
bite flip here that I think that bullies
are behaving like selfish [__] and
like all other selfish [__] whether
they're narcissists Mackie of aliens
Psychopaths they're ruining it for
everybody I I have no patience for that
behavior now of course everybody at some
point unless you're a saint does
something bad so I I don't want to be
Rock Bottom agreeableness high schoolers
and never forgive anybody but for the
people who are doing it regularly
just to benefit themselves [__] you
we're standing up to you you're not
doing it and
the ironic thing about it
is that in the long run the data is also
really clear that the best way to be
popular and liked
is to be powerful and kind
those are the people it's not a shock
but it it surprises me how bullies
overlooked that that if you really want
to be not just popular but people want
to hang around you and want to be with
you and you're enduringly thought of in
a good way you have to be kind so
ultimately they're trying to take a
shortcut to just get what they need for
their own selfish needs and in the long
run I think it it's going to burn them
funny folk ladies and gentlemen Tony I
absolutely adore your work I think this
is fascinating uh you've got like a
million other things I want to talk to
you about so let's let's line up and
talk about psychopathy or personality or
something else soon if the people that
are listening think that they want to
learn more about the work that you do
and your lab and stuff where should they
go
yeah as I said I generally stay off
social media uh but if you Google me
Tony t-o-n-y Vogue bees and Victor olk
uh on Google you'll get one of my
research lab Pages uh and then look it
up and send me an email if you want to
get in touch damn right Tony I
appreciate the hell out of you thank you
man no problem great chatting what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace